now we're also learning more tonight
about buckhead now
it's a suburb of atlanta part of atlanta
i used to do my radio show from there
one point my career
to try and separate from atlanta the
city over recent crime surge
now the nation so divided so many issues
prosperity freedom
capitalism versus socialism new green
dealism versus
oh energy independence open borders
amnesty versus secure borders defunding
the police
versus law and order it's a trend now
that we're gonna
we apparently are seeing more and more
and more of
i mean the way new york and california
look to a lot of the country
it's almost unrecognizable from the
lives they're living
localities are now separating one uh
from another with the country literally
dividing itself
believe it or not the 19th century
federal congressional resolution that
admitted the state of texas into the
union
contained language that actually
indicates that texas if they wanted
could split into five different states
of course for that to happen it would
likely still need congressional approval
but that's up for
constitutional review that's why we
brought in the great one
he's the host of the number one show
life liberty in levin every sunday night
that book over his shoulder on your
screen right now american marxism
yeah that book is uh the antidote and
the salvation for this country it gives
you the answers
coming out soon mark levine great one
you know when you get to the point when
we have such and we've had
differences throughout this country i
want us to be the united states of
america mark i know you do too
but i i hear this chatter this talk more
you hear look at buckhead they don't
want to be a part of atlanta
uh if the democrats in fact if they put
dc puerto rico statehood i've heard a
lot of people talking about texas
separating into five separate states any
truth to this
let's talk about the legality the
constitutionality thereof
well it's not so simple because we
fought a civil war
and so whatever statute was passed prior
to the civil war may really have no
meaning whatsoever the democrats have
put this into play with sanctuary cities
and sanctuary states and nullification
which they barred from their democrat
party ancestors during the confederacy
i think the problem here sean is the
centralization of power
and the effort to destroy federalism in
this country
and federalism is the glue that keeps
the country together
because people are mobile they can move
from one state to the other if you like
high taxes
lots of crime and you don't support
property rights you can move to
california or new york if you like
liberty and low
taxes and and and that sort of thing you
can move to florida and tennessee and so
forth what's happening is the failing
states
and the failing ideology the democrat
party is seeking to universalize
and devour all those who disagree with
it you can see it in their proposals
the centralization of power the
centralization of health care the
centralization of court decisions
open borders no matter what the states
think and this is
uh obviously quite contrary to the
constitutional construct
now i wanted to mention something you
mentioned my book american marxism
we have the chief of naval operations
his name is admiral michael gilday
and he may have been a great warrior as
an admiral
he needs to be fired he won't be fired
because he's joe biden's
lackey but this is a man who is
encouraging
personnel in the navy to read one of the
most racist books
in modern times by this fellow by the
name of kindy
and kindy isn't writing about civil
liberties and civil rights
and real diversity or anything of the
sort people need to understand something
and i want to take a minute here
and when we do the book later a month or
so i want to take a lot of time on it
critical race theory is a marxist based
ideology it's not even about race
it's about destroying the existing
society using race
using gender using the climate
using immigration whatever it is it was
developed by marxists in berlin
some of whom came to the united states
some of whom became tenured professors
one in particular
he was behind the new left movement in
the 1960s and he was behind this
movement
that's taken off now critical race
theoreticians reject
listen martin luther king they believe
if you believe in a colorblind society
you are a sellout
you're part of the white supremacy
dominant society
they reject the 1964 and 65 civil rights
acts as halfway measures to cover up for
white supremacy
they reject the outcome of the civil war
all the advances that have been made
they reject so when you see
fools out there fools whether they're
basketball players or professors whether
they're politicians or the president of
the united states
embracing this ideology they're
rejecting all the advances of the civil
rights movement
of the supreme court decisions uh all
the advances in congress
they are rejecting that which has taken
place in this country and they're
embracing marxism now why am i bringing
up
the chief of naval operations of our
navy
admiral michael gildays promoting a book
that's written by this by kendy who is
an
absolute out of the closet bigot in my
opinion
and sue me pal because i'll prove it and
i'll counter sue you and i'll get all
the proceeds from your damn book
now here's the thing this admiral
in charge of the navy is pushing a
marxist ideology
you want to push a book admiral push
this one that's the enemy
you're promoting the enemy in the united
states military
joe biden is promoting the enemy
throughout the united states government
it is shocking what's taking place in
this country and it's not just him
and he should be out if he doesn't even
know who the enemy is
you have an attorney general by the name
of merrick garland
who doesn't merit being attorney general
of the united states thank god he didn't
wind up with the united states supreme
court they promoted him as a moderate
this judicial figure he is a radical and
he has radicals under him the civil
rights division is now led
by a racist anti-semitic bigot based on
her own writings and her own statements
he wants to double her staff so they can
sue republican legislatures you know
because they want it to be like the
robert kennedy era where he's going
after the segregated south
that's what they're trying to do this
man made a speech the other
day in which he yes we can do this next
time
no but mark's pokemon i'll deal with him
marxism
is in bookstores soon
amazon.comhannity.com
every sunday night life liberty and
levin 8 p.m here on the channel when we
come back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else